the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well I want to be in by asking what's
what seems an obvious question what is
film one way to think of it I used to
sometimes presented by saying film as
dot dot dot film as what and it may be
surprising to you but one way we could
think about film is as chemistry now how
could that make sense why would it make
sense to think of film as a form of
chemistry
what has film got to do with chemistry
in fact it's a very fundamental relation
what what is it what it's this is also
true of of still photography as well as
movies but what is it what well what's
the process by which they're made yes
speak loudly so they fill is made up of
a lot of different components you you
have your lighting your seeing your
character and that all has to come
together to make film about one
component of it
you're losing part of the experience ok
you're right about that but that's a
more general answer than I want it oh
it's what there's something much more
dramatically fundamental about the way
about the connection between chemistry
and movies what is it it doesn't have to
do with the experience of movies come on
but it's technical it depends on
chemistry film is a form of applied
chemistry y40
yes what is a film you know there are
certain emotions that are put on a that
are put on a piece of celluloid light
it's actually has to normally it can be
any light but sunlight is best act
interacting with those emotions causes
the image to appear the actual
fundamental process by which film is
physically created is a chemical process
and one could claim if you think about
that if you reflect on it for a moment
one of the things this suggests is that
film that when then when we think about
filming the much larger sense in the
film as we experience in theaters film
ezza
as an engine of economic development as
a provider of jobs and careers and so
forth what we could say is that it is
the it is a form of applied chemistry
that is that is among the most profound
uses of chemistry that humankind has
ever found because if you think about
the impact of movies on human life and
it is now a global phenomenon is there
any culture that is free of movies any
into maybe there are Taliban cultures
that dream of being free of movies but
to my knowledge there is no culture in
the world now that's completely
oblivious to film it's become a global
phenomenon and and it's a more than a
century old it is the distinctive
narrative form of the 20th century the
signature form of storytelling for the
20th century all of it derives from this
chemical reaction when the emotions are
subjected to light that the image
appears on the cell you look and and and
there are even people who fear
theoreticians of movies who have
suggested that there's a fundamental
break of a kind that is subliminal and
less obvious to many people but is
fundamental to our experience of texts
when we move from real film to digital
forms of filmmaking because because
nature is eliminated in digital form
there's something natural and in fact
slow about the way nature worked with
the way when light works on those
emotions to bring the and to bring the
images up and those of you are amateur
photographers will know that you can
control the clarity or the blurriness of
the image the darkness or the lightness
of the image by how long you leave the
the film the film paper in the emulsions
right you can control it in
at creative still photographers and
creative movie directors actually use
those that use that that that that react
that that chemical principle in order to
create certain kinds of effects so one
way to think about movies is to think of
it as a form of applied chemistry and
one of the most profound uses of
chemistry in terms of that we could
imagine in terms of its impact on
society in terms of the the vast number
of people who have been affected and
continue to be affected by by this
invention we could also think of film so
film is a form of chemistry I mean and
we what I'm suggesting these different
framings of what film is these different
frameworks for understanding film um one
thing I'm trying to do is to suggest
some of the ways in which we might
understand film apart from what we're
going to be doing in this course now I
don't know if one could make a fool if
one if one could justify persuading a
professor of chemistry to teach a course
in film that might be going too far but
certain principles of a certain broad
principles of photography and how they
are linked to other photochemical
processes might very well make a quite
exciting and complicated course in in
the chemistry department one can also
think of film as simply in a historical
sense certainly as a kind of novelty
when film first appeared in the world
well and especially in the United States
it was seen as a novelty that that that
caused its first appearance to be take
to take place in places like Penny
arcade's where people went to experience
other kinds of public novelties as well
they would they would there would be
machines in the in these Penny arcade's
that would guess your weight and you put
a penny in and if the Machine were if
the machine was right it kept your penny
if the Machine was wrong it would give
you your penny back they were
fortune-telling machines in these Penny
arcade's they were little in some of the
more sleazy ones they were live peep
shows well in what strip shows of
various moderate moderate kinds and of
course as even at the very early stages
of film that film began to replicate
those live performing they were
very trivial forms of forms of burlesque
began to and women stripping I don't
think there were any male strippers in
this late Victorian era began to appear
in the Penny arcade's as well so one
could say that what film in its earliest
stages was also just a kind of novelty
item like a PEZ dispenser or or so or
some equivalent kind of silly thing or
or baseball cards or football cards that
that kind of thing more profoundly of
course we could think of film from
another a manufactured object and this
identity of film is incredibly important
it's again easy for us to forget because
when we go to the movies we today we see
these complex and overwhelming audio we
have these complex and overwhelming
audio-visual experiences and we might
tend to forget what in fact is the sort
of industrial base on which movies were
made at a relatively early stage part of
what we want at least to be aware of in
our course even though we won't study it
systematically is the fact that the
movies the film is one of the first
significant commodities to become a
mass-produced item and in and in fact
the same principles that led to the
MARAC to another manufacturing miracle
that we associate with the late 19th and
early 20th century the automobile the
same principles that went to the
production of the automobile also worked
with it worked in the production of film
that is to say what had to be and in
fact both film and the automobile could
be seen as prototypical instances of
this fundamentally defining industrial
capitalist behavior capitalist activity
which is mass production and especially
what does mass production depend upon
the specialization of Labor the
rationalizing of the production process
into smaller and smaller units so that
particular people can do it quickly and
you can create essentially an assembly
line production you can create mass
production but the notion I still find
it very inspiring and important
significant the notion that that that
film was created on an assembly line and
that just like toasters or automobiles
seems a shocking and important insight
because they're still in some
fundamental way produced like this there
I don't I don't mean that the same movie
studios are churning out 500 movies a
year which is what was churned out
during the great era of the Hollywood
studios from around 1930 through the end
of the 1940s but the fact is the
production of movies the manufacture of
movies still depends on these principles
of the of the specialization of Labor
and I'm not simply talking about the way
in which we have actors and directors
and cinematographers and grips and best
boys and set dressers and makeup people
and stand writers script writers and so
forth all relevant to this but I'm also
talking about the way in which movies
still to this day are divided in their
production principles in in in three
were in three stages a pre-production
phase of production phase and a
post-production phase and there are
specialists at each level on each on
each phase and and a vast army of
specialists is is a hired to handle the
problems that are connected to the
production of every single film so we
can think of films as a really
distinctive signature instance of what
mass production is capable of ok so so
we can say that the film is a
manufactured object and not just a
manufactured object but a product of
mass production a product of us
essentially assembly line principle and
what makes this so remarkable to me
still an idea that I have trouble fully
absorbing is that the manufacture that
the mass-produced item that we're
talking about unlike a toaster or even
an automobile managed so fully to
permeate our society in our world that
it's infiltrated ourselves even into our
dreams and our fantasy life and finally
another way to think about film and I'm
sort of enlarging and this is a way
we'll be talking about quite a lot in
the course of our discussions in this
semester we can say that film after it's
elaborated and and and established
itself in culture is it becomes a
fundamental social form of fundamental
social formation and experience widely
practiced widely indulged in by a vast
number of people in the society it
becomes
so there's a difference between so that
one could say for example toasters are
important but they don't they they don't
generate the kind of social rituals that
are involved in going to the going to
the movies and of identifying with movie
stars and of generating fans around
movies and more and L ancillary complex
activities that we associate that we
associate with movie going and in fact
one might say that the great era of
movie going is already gone that it was
really in the era of the Hollywood
studios when there were before the
internet and before television so we
could also then think of the film as a
social form as not when it first appears
when it's just a novelty but after it
goes through various phases when it
embeds itself into the society the way
the movies did it becomes a kind of
social form and one might almost argue
that it becomes one of the most
important social forms in the society
because it's so widely shared most
social activities in the society are
relatively limited in the circle of
people they involve right even the
number of automobile drivers is
controlled in a way that is less
contained or or demarcated in a way
that's less true of movies appeal to
children as well as adults write it they
move and from their very beginning this
has been true of movies especially in
the United States they've appealed
across lines of social stratification
across differences of gender across
differences of age across differences of
race there's one book on the film rather
overly optimistic one that simplifies
the pernicious or sinister aspect of
movies called film the Democratic art
and you can understand even though I
think it's a simplification why that's
an interesting way to think about movies
because it reached it reached so widely
to across so many social bear in that
sense film was the narrative form that
reached a wider audience than any other
narrative system that had been invented
by human beings before it what's one
explanation for why film would be so
appealing be even more appealing than
printed narrative it also is connected
to why the movies grew so quickly in
their infancy why they went from being a
novelty to being an embedded social form
so quickly let me but you
probably know what the answer is seeing
me yes that's the real answer isn't it
that it's mostly a visual medium it
doesn't depend on language to the same
degree and especially silent film right
which did not depend which it did depend
on language it used injure titles and
things but it depended on language
minimally and in the United States
infancy there was also and this was a
kind of a fundamental enabling condition
for the development of movies there was
also in the United States a vast and
growing immigrant population in all the
major cities but especially Chicago New
York some of the other larger industrial
cities and this newly this new immigrant
population which bears many of them
didn't know English at all had only a
little bit of money to disposable income
but they needed entertainment and the
silent film was the perfect answer to
this the film relatively quickly becomes
a profoundly embedded social form it be
and to give you some sense of how
monumental and how central how important
this was an American society when I can
just simply remind you of is that for
the for the for the majority of for most
of the period in which the Hollywood
studios were operating at full power
roughly the period from the advent of
sound film in the late 20s until the
late 40s when television intervened and
the even though there's a period when
television is around when when the
Moving Studios retain something of their
old character but they begin to decline
without fully realizing it that occurs
in the mid-50s sometimes so in the
period from roughly 1930 to say were
1955 to be crude about it in this period
the vast majority of Americans went to
the movies every single week think about
that every single week this was before
television which supplanted that quality
of movies right well and by in 1947 or
1948 80 million Americans went to the
movies every week every week that that
was like two-thirds of the population at
that time so it was near to being a
universal experience and not just a
universal experience that occurred
occasionally but a routine experience
and experience that families and
individuals and young
an old CAD regularly as a fundamental
part of their life right as a part of
their ordinary experience that's that's
what I mean by an embedded social form
that's an immensely important fact about
the movies and especially about the
classic movies and when that feature the
idea of the movies as something routine
in a human in people's lives something
they did regularly not occasionally when
that feature disappears it disappears in
part because of the impact of television
on society if televisions in the house
right so it's a lot easier to retain to
establish a and habitual relation to
television it is to the movie so the
advent of this new technology changed
movies relation to its audience and this
is a fact that we will to which again we
will return again and again so we can
think of we could also frame movies in
other ways but these framings I think
are helpful to us
in part to remind us of some things that
I'm not going to do one could certainly
imagine a course in a Department of
Economics that looks simply at the film
at film as an economic engine at the
number of jobs created by movies not
just the immediate jobs well the people
who are actually producing the film but
II but but but uh another kind of
another kind of accounting that would
take account of all the sort of
ancillary jobs the theater owners the
popcorn sellers the people who create
the publicity for movies the great the
whole entourage of hangers-on you're
thinking of the TV show aren't you the
whole entourage of hangers-on that
follow the movie stars around I mean
it's an unbelievable engine of economic
development and economic growth and it
is it is arguable given the fact that
the movies have been a dominant industry
in the Western world and especially in
the United States since the early 20th
century one could one could make an
argument that it's one of the most
productive and central engines of
economic growth that capitalism has ever
developed and one could teach a course
in in the movies that simply emphasized
its and its economic aspects its power
as an employer its jits
its role as a generator of of wealth as
a generator of resources and I mentioned
this partly to clarify the extent to
which in our course we're focusing on
only ask
of what film might be but also in order
to remind you that we need to be aware
of this as a backdrop to the more
cultural and aesthetic concerns about
the content of movies and about the way
they develop the way they evolved that
will be the central energies we will be
committed to in our in our course well
one thing you need to do in order in
order to sort of experience this first
these first weeks of this course in in a
really effective way is to try to in a
certain sense get outside of your own
head get outside of your own skin we
live in such a visually saturated
environment in which audio-visual
messages are beamed at us constantly
some of us don't even have to work some
of us are connected to apparatus all the
time right we're connected to our cell
phones were connected to our computers
where it's almost as if we have audio
visual signals bombarding us 24/7 what
you need to do is think it's almost as
if you were entering a cave imagine that
you're entering a cave what I want you
to do is think away your iPod's think
away your cell phone literally think
them away imagine a world without them
imagine a world without movies a world
without television a world without radio
right go back to I want you to sort of
imaginative leap it yourself back into
the era when the first films began to
appear and try to recover something in
the of the excitement and wonder that
those earliest audiences must have felt
when they saw some of these images right
and so so the most important thing in
some sense would be that they were
ablaze they weren't taken aback by the
simple shocking wonder of movement
captured on film It was as if movement
itself something they associate with
reality could suddenly be recaptured in
film and can we show some examples of
this Greg let's say some of you have
seen one example of this remember what
in the in the recitation section when
you saw the Great Train Robbery do you
remember the moment in the Great Train
Robbery where it would
seems unconnected to the story whether I
think in some in some prints of the film
that comes at the end in some prints it
came at the beginning in some prints it
didn't occur at all where was it in the
film you saw yes yes when was they at
the-- it was at the very end it's the
moment where the guy pulls out his gun
and points it at the camera shoots and
did any of you find that odd I mean I
think you should have one reason is that
it had that it had nothing to do with
the narrative It was as if it was as if
this this is an important film it used
to be thought to be the very first story
film the very first systematic narrative
on film it's not that there are earlier
examples but it's one of the very first
and that's why I wanted you to see it
it's one of the earliest story films
it's one of the earliest films to tell a
sequential story it's actually although
it seems very primitive to you guys it's
actually a very sophisticated item and
there has been a lot of filmmaking going
on before this film is made in 1902
we'll talk a little bit about that in a
moment so this moment where he where he
shoots the gun to the camera why is that
disturbing to us or strange to us I'll
answer my own question one it's
disturbing to us because it breaks the
narrative it seems unconnected to the
narrative why would they do it why do
you and then second what's going on
there why is he doing it is that does
the filmmaker not like his audience and
what's what's the reason for why do you
think it's there who has an idea why
would it be there again enter the cave
think yourself back to an era before
movie when people had never seen movies
before what's the answer is the audience
well it does engage them but what else
does it do what does it call attention
to
it puts them into a situation that they
were not encountered okay that's right
well yes in a way that's right and in
fact there are a lot of accounts of
early films playing these kinds of
tricks and audiences not yet sure of
what films were reacting as if they were
looking at something real so there are
at least reports of people seeing this
film when the guy shot to get people
screaming and ducking down under their
seats right and there are many stories
like this about early films where people
would come to and that's why they showed
it they showed it because it's a very
dramatic way of of dramatizing of
crystallizing the difference between
reality and movies and also the
extremest ik movies can be the name
movies names the most fundamental
feature of the movies that the or that
the early audiences right it's a dead
metaphor for us we don't even think
about it when we say movie but what
think what it means it means movement
films capture movement when he just
showed these in sequence while I talked
Greg okay
these are a sequence of early films and
you can see that what all of them have
in common is a fascination with motion
right in other words the novelty of
motion was so great in the beginning
that the earliest film simply did this
they said look we can show it and
there's an important principle here
about the way all media develop right in
their infancy the first thing that
happens is that that no one really sort
of much knows how a particular medium
should be or could be developed and part
of the reason that either that for the
for these early weeks in the film for
the first sort of two or three weeks in
this course is to put you back into that
situation to try to in a very
crystallized and distilled way because
there are thousands of films made in
this era but in a very distilled and
crystallized way I'm trying to recapture
some of that excitement for you and in
the case of both Chaplin and Keaton what
I've done is choose some short films
they made earlier and then show you a
feature film so that what if you watch
the Chaplin Keaton films in sequence to
shorts and then of that and then a a
feature film you'll see an acted in a
kind of small compass in within the
terms of a single directors career this
larger process that I'm saying was also
enacted by movies themselves it was this
period of the silent era
was a period in which the movies
discovered their identity or such
identity as they have and I want to talk
a bit more about that what all of these
early relatively primitive of films show
us is a kind of this is a very faint one
of the earliest some people call this
the first comedy film the first joke
okay okay right but it is it seems to us
the simplicity of it seems to us weird
right but if you think yourself back if
you go into the cave try to imagine a
universe without audio visual stimuli
you can begin to understand why some of
this stuff why some of this stuff was so
interesting motion itself cap itself
captivated early audiences and
filmmakers waves on the shore for
example is there there's there a number
of films that just show waves lapping on
the shore many films of trains coming
into stations and of course there's Fred
on sneezing have we shown the kiss for
the electric you did can we do that
right there were also risque or anarchic
elements that showed up in the early
film that I want you to see here is a is
one of the most famous and scandalous of
early films something called the kiss
and it was an unbelievable scandal when
it came out it films a scene from a
stage play it was it look how short it
was it was banned in many cities they
would call it was thought to be
scandalous he let's let's let's look at
do you have the you have the electric
you alright many people would call this
the first snuff film and this is this is
this is a film called and elected the
electrocution of an elephant and think
again what's going on here part of it
has to do with this wonder that the film
can capture actuality in a way the
belief that right look there's something
we're bizarre and gross about this in
some way the camera was set up they this
was a rogue elephant that was about to
be put to death
so they were going to electrocute the
elephant and they brought a camera there
to witness the electrocution and of
course it's so dark because this
fragment of film survives from over a
hundred years ago more than a hundred
years he's supposed to collapse not to
stand up his knee oh there it is
grotesque isn't it but also a part of
early film in other words this idea that
film could capture reality was itself so
it was the novelty of this was so
powerful that in the early stages this
was enough to cause could to cause great
excitement for audiences one way to
think about this problem and to think
about the the what would the way oh the
way I have for sort of encapsulating or
or or dramatizing in a kind of in a kind
of a distilled way all the elaborate
processes that go into that that went
into the development or the evolution of
film is by the way I do this in part is
by reference to old Fred this this film
used to be thought to be the very first
film it's not actually it's one but it
is one of the earliest films made and
patented in Edison's movie studio the
very first movie studio in the United
States in East Orange New Jersey
probably this made in 1894 at least the
copyright I think is for Fred OTT
sneezes in 1894 and think how simple it
is how ridiculous it is a camera sets up
they were still working on the
technology of the motion picture camera
at this stage and they were testing it
out and Fred OTT was an employee of the
Edison Company and they said to Fred
okay Fred stand in front of the camera
and take snuff and that's what he's
doing we might think of Fred acts knees
as theoretically symbolically the first
film even though there are earlier film
well think of how unbelievably simple it
is show it once more Greg and can you
can you can you freeze it so that Fred
stays on the screen while we're while
we're talking about this so look how
short it is what is it's two seconds
long right
the think of this are two seconds so
this film is made in whatever-it-is 1894
1895 right this two-second long film is
made in 1894 1895 by 1920 by the 1920s
astonishingly complex narrative films
are being made great works of art are
being made what I call the Fred OTT
principle is this whole complex
so social and-and-and and technical and
technological and and
and artistic process the swirling of all
of these energies going together
including the demographic fact of so
many immigrant audiences creating an
environment that made early film a very
profitable activity despite how crude it
was right what happens in this period
between 1900 and the end of the 20s is
that film goes from being a novelty
separated off sharing a space in the
penny arcade's with other forms of
novelty to being one of the dominant
industries and one of the dominant
social experiences of the American
population this principle is replicated
in some other European societies as well
but not in all it's an it's an advanced
capitalist event and it occurs in other
societies less fully industrialized at
later stages but there is an equivalent
history in some of the European cultures
so in this period of less than a few of
fewer than 30 years film goes from being
the most trivial and simplified kind of
novelty to being one of the most complex
narrative forms human beings have ever
devised what I mean by the Fred OTT
principle is that whole complex process
that we can go from something so simple
to something so complex from something
so marginal in society to something so
central in society in such a short time
and I want to at least remind you of
what that principle involves I'm talking
about all the technological cultural
demographic and economic currents that
swirl together to create the movie
industry that that emerges really by the
mid teens the movie industry essentially
is in place variations will occur new
studios will look you will appear but by
the middle of by the by the by 1915 1916
American American movies have been
established on an assembly line basis
and one way to think about what I'm to
have been established on a on an
assembly line basis and millions and
millions of people are now making it a
regular habit to go to the movies and
the movies are elaborating themselves in
a complex way that has to do with the
way in which they were industrialized
there are three phases I think to what
we might call let's
go back to the outline grade there are
three phases to what we might call tech
media evolution and and this is another
way of sort of dramatizing what I mean
by the Fred OTT principle the first
phase is a phase of imitation and patent
warfare a new technology appears nobody
yet knows how it would be applied what
how people will want to do everything
about that about the new technology is
up for grabs so there are there are
competitors who want to sort of claim
patents on the technology questions
about how long will should films be
where should films be shown right
how should films be distributed all of
that's up for grabs and all of that is
rationalized then and and decided I put
decided in quotes because no one sort of
sits down and makes a decision it's
really a function of the marketplace and
of certain economic opportunities right
there's no question for example that the
movies would never have developed as
they did were it not for those immigrant
populations in cities like Chicago and
New York and Los Angeles and many many
other cities on the East Coast
especially where there were very large
immigrant populations who needed what
and and and it was it was it was that
financial infusion that that caused the
immense amount of experimentation and
developed development to take place so
quickly so in this first phase of
imitation and patent warfare many of
these questions are not even even such
simple questions as you know how long a
film should be some of the some of the
question of the length of the film are
technological the very first films had
to be only 10 minutes long because that
was as long as the film cartridges in
which they which they put in the cameras
were capable of doing later they were
able to make two reelers and three
reelers that happens over over a
relatively short space of time so so in
this phase of imitation one of the most
important things that happens and this
is the part I want you to become
attentive to is that all of the ancestor
systems that lie behind the new
technology are potential influences on
the new technology and in new films that
you've seen already the the silent films
you saw in recitation you saw some
examples of this certain for example do
you remember that maybe we could show
this Gregg this the
that see the deaths in the Great Train
Robbery remember the the deaths in the
great train robber you smiling because
they were so noticeably what false fake
yeah where do they come from memory with
a guy shoots in the guy go and he
staggers around and then he falls what
what what's going on where does that
tradition of performance come from yeah
yes I'll let it play behind me you could
say yes it comes from theater makes
sense that the first that one of the
deep influences on early film would be
theater but but now in the Fed principle
the most important the most important
sub idea in the fore in this theory of
or in this label the Fred OTT principle
is the fact that this process of
development involves among other things
the power of film make the capacity of
filmmakers to discover those features of
the new medium that are unique or
special to the medium what makes the
medium different from its ancestors
clearly what was appropriate for books
or newspapers or theatre won't be
perfectly appropriate for the new medium
but nobody knows what the new mediums
capable of until things have been tried
out so that's why I call it a phase of
imitation and what one can say here
especially is that certain theatrical
styles of acting are dominant why are
theatrical styles of acting so broad so
so unbelievable why are they why are
they like that yes you're in the theater
in the theater you're far away and
you're in a fixed base but what's the
one genius of the movies one way the
medium of the movies is different from
theater is that the camera can achieve a
lover's closeness to the action or it
can achieve a long view that's much
longer and further away than what right
well it's going to take time before this
kind of thing is figured out right and
in one of the things one of the most
decisive things we see in early films is
first an acting style that seems derived
from theater but some of you may have
noticed that this begins to change
relatively quickly can we can we show
the fragment from a beast at bay you
remember that silly film a beast at bay
that I had you watching along with the
Great Train Robbery remember the ending
of a beast at bay something odd happens
in this ending or there's that there's
the monstrous ruling
rapists like figure right he's always a
convict or a lowlife I mean there are
all kinds of social hierarchies and and
established social prejudices that get
imported into early films right and and
now we're going to get we're going to
have the rescue and so far it seems a
conventional sort of sleazy melodrama in
which there's at least a hint of
something morally disturbing in the in
the in the imminence of the rape right
and it's as if the film makes a kind of
sleazy appeal to its audience as if you
know the reviews here here's a perfect
example of such a moment right it's
interesting in fact how one of the
recurring subjects of films always seems
to be not just rape but violence against
women and we it tells you something
about the patriarchal societies in which
films emerge that those met up that
those mythologies are replicated in
movies okay so he's going to be he's
going to be rescued and what I want you
to notice is what happens at the very
end of this sequence and can some of you
remember what it is none of you remember
was so fast but it actually is very
significant I think it shows us the
emergence the beginnings of the
emergence of a new style of acting more
appropriate to movies and also something
else the development of atonal
complexity that had not been in movies
before now the date of this film is
early it's about 1907 1908 something
like that the you're going to see one
other silent film by Griffith DW
Griffith tonight the lonedale operator
made in 1912 and I hope you'll be
attentive to how much more complex that
film is I'll say a few words about that
tonight I wish we were really just at
the end Greg I didn't really want to
show the whole film
okay so here we're at the conclusion
here now this is the part I wanted you
to notice look at this
what's happening here the film has
shifted over into a kind of silly comedy
a kind of gentle comedy and and and you
know the woman in season kiss me here
kiss me here and in fact if you notice
she's not she's not saying kiss me here
right she's mean in other words her
gestures are more modulated to the
nature of movies in other words what's
beginning to happen there is two
important things first
tonal complexity is entering in a sleeve
a melodrama has turned comic right and
acting style is beginning to can we do
the very end of Musketeers
here is the very end of a film by DW
Griffith called Musketeers of Pigalle
some people see it as one of the first
urban crime films but what I want you to
watch is this small actor here watch his
performance this is the emergence of a
new kind of acting a non theatrical kind
of acting and it's happening very early
this film appeared in 1912
that's lillian gish the great famous
silent film star this gangster is
shocked that this woman would choose him
over his rival over him he says you're
nuts lady I can't get it but okay but
look at look look at the way he look at
this sort of strutting peacock of a man
watch this
he's a gangster he's about to be
arrested but they're going to the good
guys we'll save him well we lost it what
one good turn deserves another
but you see how much more restrain the
performances are here
I mean Lillian Gish became one of the
great silence screen stars but I think
it's this strutting peacock of an of an
actor who really begins to show what you
can do on film and there are many film
critics who have seen this as a
precursor of Edward G Robinson's
performances he's also a diminutive
actor often plays gangsters but what you
see I think in this moment and in this
Vance performance is the emergence the
beginnings of an acting style that's
more modulated that's appropriate to the
nature of the film so that kind of thing
is happening is not just with acting it
has to do with all kinds of things it
has to do with where you place the
camera and other such and other such
matters so so what I mean then by the
Frederick principle is this process of
evolution that I want you to be aware of
and really in a certain sense experience
in distilled form in the short films
I've asked you to watch in this first
week of classes the first phase is the
phase of imitation and patent warfare in
which all kinds of questions are up in
the air
how will the film be distributed how
will it be how will it be exhibited
how will it be produced but I mean
there's nothing inherent in the nature
of the technology that requires the
economic arrangements that developed in
the United States and then were
replicated elsewhere for the
distribution of movies in fact Thomas
Edison had a different idea for how
movies would be developed when he first
conceived the apparatus he actually
thought that movies would be movie
projectors would be owned by each
individual and that people would make
they were in fact what he was imagining
was the TV the camcorder that occurred
that occurs in a much later generation
my way well and and and there's nothing
inherent in the technology that would
not permit that so this so one of the
things we're also aware we need to be
aware of and I'll return
this matter either tonight or in a later
lecture we need to be aware of the fact
that the shape the technology takes is
not the only shape it might take that
it's not it's not the technology itself
that drives its development so much as
economic and social and demographic
factors right and and that's that's
dramatically the case with the system of
distribution and access that was
developed for the movies it's certainly
theoretically possible for the apparatus
to be developed in a way that would be
sold to every individual what instead
happened was a system in which a
professional elite becomes the
production arm and these productions
become very expensive and they are and
they are pumped out into the Society for
dit for for screening at public theaters
which people will pay money to attend
that that that economic structure and
that basic industrial structure is not
necessary to the technology it's not
required by the technology the shape of
film is at least as much cultural as it
is technological right very important
very important point so the second and
so the second phase after the phase of
imitation is the phase I call technical
advance this phase occurs this phase
occurs after some of the warfare is
concluded as limited monopolies are
established some companies are more
powerful than others who more or come up
with a more successful product than
others and they begin to dominate the
marketplace in there and their power
they draw and they drive competitors out
and what essentially happens is a kind
of stability is introduced in which the
basic system is put in place here's how
we'll manufacture the item here's how
we'll distribute it here's how we'll
here's how long it will be that sort of
thing and and in this and this period of
technical advance what happens what then
happens once the stability sets in the
particular unique features of the medium
begin to be explored and these early
films that I'm asking you to look at
what I hope you'll watch for our moments
like the ones I was just pointing out to
this this afternoon in which you see the
emergence of a recognition of something
that is distinct or special in the
nature of moviemaking I'll return to
some of these matters again tonight but
I want you to be aware of them as doing
this so in the second phase
the phase of technical advance the the
system begins to learn what is unique
about it how our movie is different from
their ancestors what does it mean that
the camera can move close to the the the
the object its photographing or very far
away from what does it mean that the
camera itself doesn't have to be stable
that it can move you can see some of the
early Griffith films really experiment
with with a camera that's mounted on
something that's on something that's
moving right and and and then the final
phase is the phase I call maturity and
that's the phase that occurs really in
silent film in the 1920s when the
technical advances that are accomplished
in part in Phase two are married to a
serious subject matter the phase I call
maturity is the phase in which feature
films are made in which some films
become works of art and all films become
more complex forms of narrative in which
particular genre forms begin to emerge
and audiences begin to choose particular
kinds of films that matter to them in
the ones the system really elaborates
itself in a you know in a way that
suggests an immense variety of appeal to
a root to a range of audience right now
that's the face of what you why doesn't
it go on forever what explains why the
process doesn't continue what stopped
this process though it's so the Fred OTT
principle and capsule means going from
Fred OTT sneeze to going to Chaplin's
modern times this immensely rich complex
narrative film that we'll be looking at
next week right what explains why that
moment of maturity doesn't extend
forever why why is the system not stable
forever the simplest answer is
capitalism never allows for stability
but the more exact answer is new
inventions new technologies subvert the
stability what happens at the end of the
20s to subvert the confidence and
stability of the system the advent of
sound yes and the sound field doesn't
completely revolutionize movies but it
profoundly alters them it changes the
nature of film and it changes the nature
of the kinds of performers that your
need in filming it it profoundly
enlarges and complicates what film is
and then the something of the same
principles that I've talked about before
happened in the sound era I'm sorry I'm
running a little over but I promise you
I'm almost done and normally I will
never
/ even by a minute I promise a work for
this in the in the in this why doesn't
the final phase continue because of new
technologies because of new
possibilities what what happens at the
end of the studio system the advent of
television overturns
the stabilities that had been created
and the old studio era and the intimate
routine connection to movies that had
been established the studio era is
finally obliterated by the presence of
television and movies change their
character after television comes in we
will return to this returned this man
well one way I can suggest for you to
sort of capture this imaginative linkage
the semantic of connection to the world
of early film as is by reminding you of
a wonderful passage from the Pulitzer
prize-winning novel by the great film
critic James Agee which appeared
posthumously in 1957 and it it distills
for me what I mean and I hope for you
what I mean in part by film as a social
form film as a as a socially embedded
formation it helps to explain in less
abstract terms what I mean when I say
that film permeated American life listen
to the beginning of from from this is
from the first chapter and we're
finished after this is over from the
first chapter of a death in the family
at supper that night as many times
before his father said well suppose we
go to the picture show Oh J his mother
said that horrid little man what's wrong
with him his father asked not because he
didn't know what she would say but so
she would say it he's so nasty she said
as she always did so vulgar with his
nasty little Kane hooking up skirts and
things and that nasty little walk who is
he talking about Chaplin Charlie Chaplin
of course and we were talking and this
this story takes place before Chaplin
was making feature films so this is
probably that story takes place probably
around 1915 when comedy was still being
made in short of
as shorts they become comedies didn't
become feature-length until sometime
late in the 20s
his father laughed as he always did and
Rufus felt that had become rather an
empty joke but as always the laughter
also cheered him he felt that the
laughter enclosed him with his father
they walked down town in the light of
mother-of-pearl to the majestic nice
name for a theatre and found their seats
by the light of the screen in the
exhilarating smell of tobacco rank sweat
perfume and dirty drawers while the
piano played fast music writes violent
films were never silent there was always
music accompanying them and galloping
horses raised a grandiose flag of dust
and there was William s heart the
passage then goes on to describe a
Western film with William s heart a
silent film and then the screen was
filled with a city and with a sidewalk
of a side street of a city and a long
line of palms and there was Charlie
everyone laughed the minute they saw him
squat Lee walking with his toes out and
his knees apart as if he were chafed
Rufus's father laughed and Rufus laughs
- laughs - this time Charlie stole whole
a whole bag this time what does that
imply about the audience an intimate
familiarity with previous adventures of
this character right an ongoing routine
in connection this time he caught a
sight at this time Charlie stole a whole
bag of eggs and when a cop came along he
hid them in the seat of his pants then
he caught sight of a pretty woman and he
began to squat and twirl his chick cane
and make silly faces I'm going to skip
it's magnificent prose that captures the
essence of the film very wonderfully but
I don't want to keep you longer than I
already have
and it shows Charlie sort of flirting
with the girl and then finally he flirts
where there's so much that she pushes
him and he falls back down and then he
walked back and forth behind her
laughing and squatting a little and
while he walked very quietly everybody
laughed again then he flicked hold of
the straight end of his cane and with
the crook then hooked up her skirt at
the knee
in exactly the way that disgusted mama
looking very eagerly at her legs and
everybody laughed very loudly then she
pretended she had not noticed and then
she pushes him over right and there was
Charlie flat on his bottom on the
sidewalk and the way
looked kind of sickly and disgusted you
could see that he suddenly remembered
those eggs and suddenly you remembered
them too
the way his face looked with his lip
wrinkled off the teeth and the little
sickly smile it made you feel just the
way those broken eggs must feel against
your seat as queer and awful as that
time in the white pique suit he's also
dramatizing how personal our relation to
film can be when it ran down out of the
pants legs and showed all over your
stockings and you had to walk home that
way with everyone looking and Rufus his
father nearly tore his head off laughing
and so did everybody else but Rufus was
sorry for Charlie having so recently
been in the similar predicament but the
contagion of laughter was too much for
him and he laughed too and the passage
goes on to describe the intimacy and the
complexity of the relations between
audiences in 1915 and one of the iconic
figures of the movies in this idea that
Charlie mobilizes these an arc this is
an Arctic liberating laughter and
mobilizes this father-son relationship
in that idea we recapture something of
what I mean by the notion that film was
an embedded social experience an
embedded social form I'll see you
tonight
you